[Music]
this week on forward
people often think of entrepreneurs as
big Risk Takers and but they aren't they
they try to measure like what's a risk I
can afford to take and and invest in
that the idea that you can be engaged in
something that is going to try to at
least control your world and maybe have
an impact on the broader world is a is a
very comforting and and empowering
feeling for young people you know what I
find to be the antidote for anxiety and
depression is action and agency I can't
tell you how many conversations I have
when I say gosh I'm a social moderate
and an economic conservative and
everyone says would you please start a
party that's for those folks because
I've never felt like I had a home and I
hope that that's at least partially what
we're doing
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the very newest member of the
national board of forward former
lieutenant governor of Massachusetts and
president of Babson College Carrie Healy
welcome Carrie thank you Andrew it's
great to be here I am so pumped to have
you as a colleague you and I met gosh
now it must be a few years ago out west
uh and I was blown away by you you're
you were so clearly principled
independent patriotic you were looking
at ways to move the country forward uh
you're now on the board of the council
for responsible social media I believe
and that's something that in my mind uh
is really high on the priority list
um and should be non-partisan so I guess
we'll lead off with that what the heck
made you say yes to joining forward
which I'm super excited about well I
guess Andrew I've been looking for a
home maybe my whole life politically you
know so so this is uh one of these
moments where I feel that I I have the
opportunity to be in on the ground floor
with you and and Governor Whitman uh to
build something that will really be
valuable for the next generation of
Americans which is to give people the
opportunity uh to express the full range
of political uh beliefs and expressions
and and to work constructively in
politics which is something I've always
wanted to do I had the opportunity to do
that in Massachusetts and in what is
probably a pretty unique environment
where Republicans and and Democrats work
very closely together uh for the good of
the people and
um and I'd love to see that across the
country and and I'd love that to to give
other people that opportunity amen so
you started out as a high school student
in Florida
um do you still spend a lot of time in
Florida where do you hang your hat
nowadays you know I don't I actually
have ended up back in Massachusetts I
just spent about three and a half years
down in Washington DC working with the
Milken Institute helping them sort out
how to found something called the center
for advancing the American dream and
that was a great experience because it
really gave me the opportunity to dive
deeply into why people are so concerned
about the future of America why they do
or do not believe that the American
dream exists now or whether it ever
existed for all people and and also what
kinds of things we might be able to do
to increase access to the American dream
and so that's that I I'm glad I spent
some time in Washington but I don't
think the answers are actually in
Washington I think the answers are out
around the country and that was
something that really made me want to
get back to Massachusetts and reimburse
myself in that culture which is so
conducive to
um to hearing different points of view
and and a very wonderful awareness of
our nation's history and the value of
that history to our values well I want
to dig into the center for advancing the
American dream and what you learn
learned and figure it out over the last
several years because you were just
starting that when you and I met out
west but first let's retrace your steps
a little bit because people are I think
always are interested in origin stories
so you uh you went to school in New
England and then you got an advanced
degree I want to say in Europe uh came
back and you wound up in politics
relatively early in your career you did
some policy research and work and then
you ran uh for uh I want to say a State
Rep seat uh and you were still
relatively young did you know you always
wanted to get into politics what was
that first race like so I I did I grew
up in Daytona Beach Florida I went to
public schools and I was interested in
politics I went up to the state house in
Tallahassee and was it a page uh in the
in the Florida legislature back in the
time when it was virtually all male and
they were having fist fights in the
hallways and it was just a very rough
and Tumble crazy environment but I was
interested in it because that's where
policy was being made and and I just I
found it fascinating and so I didn't get
involved with politics until I was
almost 37 years old but I was a I was an
observer I I was a political science
major I studied uh at Trinity College
Dublin as you mentioned and studied law
and politics and was always very
interested in how law interacted with
our policies and and what kind of
society that makes and so when I had the
opportunity
um to to begin to go into politics when
I was about 37 38 years old I had a
really strong basis of of things that I
wanted to do I'd been working for 10
years for the U.S Department of Justice
on criminal justice issues and as as you
well know uh criminal justice issues
arise out of social issues so I was
looking at things like drug abuse or
gang violence or child abuse and neglect
or domestic violence and so often when
you really dig down in those issues what
you find is addiction you find
homelessness you find a History of
Violence within someone's family you
find people who dropped out of a high
school and and really had very few
options as they were moving forward and
so after about 10 years of doing that
criminal justice research and you know
publishing papers and white papers and
going to conferences that nobody attends
I realized that if I were actually going
to do anything about this if I actually
wanted to see change in the issues that
I had at that time become very
passionate around I needed to run for
office and my idea was
even if I didn't win which I certainly
didn't I lost twice
um for the legislature
um I I would have a platform to talk
about it and I think that that's
something wonderful that everyone should
feel about politics is that politics and
our political discussion provides a
platform for you to talk about things
you care about and at that time I really
cared about uh I cared about foster
children I cared about domestic violence
I cared about drug and gang violence and
I and the and the impact on communities
that that was having and so I thought
look I'm going to run for office I'm
probably going to lose I'm I'm running
as a republican in an all-democratic
state so I can kind of see the writing
on the wall there but at least I'm going
to have a chance to talk about things I
care about and and that's how I started
that process in my late 30s well you
impressed a lot of people you wound up
in a leadership position in
Massachusetts and then got knighted to
be written Mitt Romney's lieutenant
governor uh which I dare say someone I
talked to someone about you in this
interview and they said wow Mitt Romney
history seems to be very very kind to me
in terms of both National leadership but
also what he did in Massachusetts
uh and that that must have been a really
productive feeling time for you and Mitt
it was a wonderful it was a wonderful
experience and by the way
um uh Senator Romney is just a genuinely
good person I know a lot of times people
are a little bit cynical about someone
who seems maybe a little bit too good to
be true but he is honestly a very good
person every single day of the week and
and loves his family and loves his
country and is willing to make you know
very difficult decisions for which he's
been harshly criticized by a number of
people in order to stand up for
principle so I I have nothing but the
greatest admiration for him and it was a
great experience working with him it is
funny where I feel like mitt now has
morphed into this wholesome grandfather
figure for a lot of people which I'm
sure he is both wholesome and a
grandfather
well yeah do I believe at least 25 maybe
26 grandchildren so I think the answer
is that's exactly who he is yes
um so you then ran for governor as a
republican in a very blue State
um and that didn't go your way
uh I feel like
this movement forward in many ways is
tailor-made for someone like you because
you strike me as reasonable policy
oriented moderate Blue State Republican
honestly I don't know if that's a fair
description well that's well that's
right I mean there there is a whole
category of of Republicans in the
Northeast and when Governor Romney and I
were in office together
um there were Republican Governors
throughout the the Northeast actually in
almost every state and and these are
folks who are generally described as
being socially moderate and and
economically conservative and although
it's not necessary for state level
policies uh I would also say that I
personally am a foreign policy
conservative as well I believe that
America should lead that it's Our
obligation to lead but that we shouldn't
lead with Force we should leave lead
with moral character and principle and
that we need to lead with a strong
economy and that strong economy begins
at home so so those those are the
principles that I always felt
comfortable with it's these are
principles that a number of people in
the Northeast feel comfortable with I
can't tell you how many conversations I
have when I say gosh I'm a social
moderate and an economic conservative
and everyone says would you please start
a party that's for those folks because
I've never felt like I had a home and I
hope that that's at least partially what
we're doing yeah I'm very very much so
you know Chris sununu who is a
republican Blue State gov sorry I mean
purplish state but he's a republican
he's a moderate Republican he's like the
he's top of mind for me when you think
about these Northeastern absolutely part
of that model yeah very much so and he's
stepping down not to run again
um which in some ways is very
disappointing it seems like that that
breed of Republican leader is in danger
of Disappearing well I think it's very
hard for uh individuals like that right
now to get even the nomination of their
part party in those blue States because
we have as as everyone has seen uh see
the Republican Party become quite
polarized and moderates have been forced
out you know we have seen even a
governor as wildly popular as Charlie
Baker in Massachusetts who was you know
re-elected with 70 percent of the vote
uh in a state where Republicans actually
comprise fewer than 10 percent of the
voters and he was a Republican and he
was being re-elected and his his
popularity ratings were off the chart
but he was in doubt of whether or not he
was actually going to be able to win his
own convention uh because the the party
had shrunk so much and become so extreme
uh that that they didn't they no longer
even approved him of him and approved of
what he was doing within the state so
people like that should be kept in
politics obviously because they're doing
a good job and people like them but the
party the our current party structure
doesn't allow for it
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for a
hundred night free trial you can sleep
on this thing for three months it will
keep you cool don't just take my word
for it my kids seek out this mattress in
the house it's the number one rated
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
this mattress will actually make you
happier healthier and more productive
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
yeah that that is the problem isn't it I
mean right now you have party structures
that are distorting what people want
when most Americans want uh and
unfortunately it's corrupting incentives
for a lot of political figures or
candidates I talked to some folks this
week uh and they said up front they were
like look I would never run in this
environment and most of the the good
people I know wouldn't run it's super
sad so you became the first woman
president at Babson College which is an
institution I respect and admire a great
deal it's one of the most
entrepreneurial schools in the country a
validly so I would love to hear about
your experience there particularly with
young people uh and uh and what their
sense of the future is what their sense
of uh their own trajectory and path look
like uh you were president of absent for
how many years for six years from 2013
to 2019 up to their Centennial that's a
long time and you accomplished it a
great deal there it's getting to be more
the typical length of time for a college
President College presidents used to
stay forever but now it's more like six
to seven years
um and and I have to say I'm so pleased
that I went to Babson in particular
because of their focus on
entrepreneurship uh what I got to see is
that you know so many young people uh
feel disempowered you know they they
feel that they're worried about the job
market they're going into they're
worried about how jobs of the future are
going to be different than the ones they
have they're worried whether or not they
should be spending as much money as they
are to get the college education that
they are and yet when you're at a
college like Babson where you know 99 of
the the graduates have a good paying job
within six months of graduation there's
no sense of return on investment not
being there you know people know that
they're going to get value for their
money in that environment and right now
I think there are so many questions
about the overall value you of higher
education and whether people ought to be
going into debt to get you know that
that kind of credential that we really
need to refocus on things like
entrepreneurship that that give people
first of all the power to create their
own job right they don't have to wait
around for someone else to provide an
opportunity to them but they can use
their own initiative their own talents
uh and to work with others who have a
similar entrepreneurial uh mentality but
also those are job creators right those
are the people who are not just going to
take a job created by somebody else
they're going to create not only a job
for themselves but they're going to
create jobs for other people too and and
they are seeing problems and they're
creating solutions for those problems
that are going to be economically
advantageous to their communities and
their country so I loved working with
those kids and they are the most
energized optimistic International group
of students that you'll find yeah I I
have a number of friends from Babson but
two come to mind one started a business
a rock climbing gym business and then
the other became a very senior executive
at L'Oreal cosmetics and as a result I
just think of Babson folks as really
smart practical uh get stuff done
and I I can see you as a president who's
very happy to reinforce that that kind
of culture so I get asked all the time
by parents advice for young people
you're a parent yourself though your
kids are probably
um past college and whatnot they're
around 30 they're around 30. yeah so
when when parents ask you for advice
about their kids or when even they they
did when you were president of Babson
what did you tell them
well one of the things that I always
emphasize to parents because they get so
nervous around this notion of choosing a
college and they worry that if they
don't choose the right college that
their their child's life will be ruined
or if they don't get into this specific
Elite college that the life their life
is over is just that there are so many
wonderful paths to take and and there's
so many wonderful institutions out there
and so it's really incumbent on parents
right now and students I would prefer
the student to do the research to figure
out you know what is the right fit and
match for that particular student and
their Ambitions and their talents and
their learning style it there isn't a
right place for everyone not everyone
should go to Harvard even if they could
and and it's just not it opening up
admissions to at least Elite
institutions isn't the the necessary
answer for all of this it's telling
everyone you don't have to go to Elite
institutions uh to maybe to get to where
you want to go really think hard about
what kind of life you want to live where
you want to live it what region what you
want to do do and then find the place
that specializes in what you really love
and what you enjoy
um that's that's the trick that's the
hard part find the right fit it's not
about looking at the rankings it's about
finding the right fit it's no it's not
although I think return on investment is
good I think you need to look if you're
going to look at a ranking I would look
at return on investment because you know
like college education that isn't no but
you know increasingly they are starting
to come out with different measures of
return on investment money management
Money Magazine is doing it
um even some of the the more traditional
U.S news and World reports are trying to
take a stab at it but looking at the
alumni is probably the best measure just
as you were saying hey I keep bumping
into Babson graduates who are doing fun
things and interesting things with their
lives I think that's always a very good
way to figure out if that's a good place
for you to go all right so I have a a
big question for you which is teaching
entrepreneurship so I I ran an
entrepreneurship organization that I
started for six years so I have a sense
as to how we went about it but one joke
I used to tell so this is a true fact
that even as the number of
Entrepreneurship programs on college
campuses have multiplied the rates of
business formation among College age
people have plummeted so you have more
programs and fewer actual businesses
getting started
um so here is my joke Carrie you can
respond to it I used to say if you
wanted a really effective
entrepreneurship course the professor
would just say on day one if you take
this course everyone here gets an f and
then whoever shows up in week two
actually has the makeings of an
entrepreneur because they would accept
because they're accepting failure or
um hey I'm going to determine your grade
be a random dice rolls
because everyone who's like oh I need an
a I need an a we'll we'll jet
um and the folks who are wired that way
you know might not actually want to go
through the
um the trials and tribulations of
starting a business so how did you all
go about uh training aspiring
entrepreneurs well you know this is such
a fascinating question right because
um it wasn't even entrepreneurship was
not even an academic subject uh 35 40
years ago it was considered to be
something that either you were born with
and you went off and did uh or or it was
something that you had a business plan
and you you know you were more of a sort
of an engineer and you you prepared
business plan there used to be business
plan competitions where people would
look at it what we did at Babson was
very different which was we threw
everyone in off the deep end immediately
in their first year and one of one class
that everyone had to take was to start a
start a business and they form teams and
they thought about different ideas and
they voted on the ideas and the bad
ideas were washed out and over the
course of the the year they built a
business uh literally built it got all
the permits they needed to they had some
seed funding that was given to them by
the college not a lot but some and and
then by the end of the year they had to
either give their profits to a
non-profit or pay back the seed funding
and give the profits away or if they
just washed out well that's the way it
is but they weren't graded as you
mentioned they weren't graded on whether
they made money at the end of the time
they were graded on did they learn from
the process did they learn how to put
together a team did they figure out you
know how to manage cash flow did they
figure out how to just say this is a bad
idea we need to start over we need to
Pivot and go do something else you know
so if they learned and they could stand
up at the end and say boy I failed
miserably and this is how I failed and
why then that person would get an A okay
okay this raises so many questions that
I must know the answer to
so first what year are they when they
take this course second they're 18 years
it's a freshman year of course which is
awesome yeah second how are the teams
arranged and how many students are in
are on each team
some some of these teams are up to maybe
15 people but others end up being quite
small because there's there are moments
when people can defect from one team and
go to another team if they think that
they aren't getting along or if they get
fired but how are they uh initially
arranged is it a bunch of people get
together and say okay we're a team or is
it I'd grab you and say Hey guys you're
a team like how does that work I I
believe that they actually have to form
their own teams around they usually form
teams around the ideas that Inspire them
so so the first part is the general idea
generation and and so then then they
sort of gather around like oh yeah I
believe this idea can work I'd like to
work on that and the third thing is and
the sums are probably very modest
um but how much was it and was it
assigned per student so if I had a
10-person team we got uh you know 10 10x
yeah I I I'm afraid I I've lost track
over the last few years of how much
money it is but it's it's fewer than a
couple thousand dollars I can I can say
that um so but is that on a per head
basis or so if I get more students do we
get more money
as I read college per team I don't know
I I need to get a professor on here to
uh to answer some of these questions but
um but it's enough money so that they
can you know do something they can start
um you know and and then you know they
they hopefully make up make a little bit
money over time I love that so much on
so many levels and one of the my
frustrations with a lot of these things
is they don't make it real if you put
even a very very small amount of money
it becomes real uh and so I I love the
fact that you're actually doing that and
trusting them and treating them like
adults because one of the things I heard
from some young people who take an
entrepreneurship class is that it
actually seems more daunting after you
learn about oh there's you know that
like making a business plan I mean the
fact is X years ago no one made a
business plan they just uh freaking
started selling whatever the heck they
were selling you know it was whether it
was cakes or flowers or singing
telegrams or whatever it was like no one
was coming up with the plan so uh so the
fact that that it's real and there's
real money involved and the real
relationships at stake uh it is awesome
well I think it's also important because
people often think of entrepreneurs as
these single individuals who go out and
do it all alone but of course that's
never true you have to build a team
around you and so the notion that that
team Dynamic and the fact that you can't
really do anything alone uh you really
do need support of one way or another is
is a good lesson to learn right up front
and one of the some of the research that
was done at Babson that I thought was
fascinating was that three three-person
teams were most likely to succeed that's
the greatest freaking data point I've
ever heard isn't that great and then and
then more than three was like less
likely to succeed but like three people
apparently yeah more chefs in the
kitchen no one has any real
responsibility or like yeah it that
person's annoying and so I'm gonna check
out
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andreyang.com books and there's a
special discount code last election that
you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
Carrie I'm I love entrepreneurship
dearly
um I love entrepreneurship one because
like you said it's job creating uh and
and
um but also it's self-actualizing it's a
if you tell someone look you have to go
build it you have to solve a problem you
care about that's just a very different
process and a different set of uh people
that result then hey your goal is to get
this badge and then if you get that
badge then you'll get in you'll get into
this org and then they'll reward you a
lot and then you know it's it's just a
different mindset I spent six and a half
years uh training young entrepreneurs
I'm still involved with a number of
startups today
um and so I I love the fact that you
also were a part of cultivating that in
the Next Generation and like you said
it's not necessarily that you're gonna
go out and start a company uh you know I
mean you can join a firm in various ways
I did write a book on this subject uh
called smart people should build things
about entrepreneurship
um uh back in my adventure for America
days
um I don't know if you'd ever you
probably wouldn't have I mean there are
a lot of Entrepreneurship books out
there but but that that was about my
time training entrepreneurs no but I'm
going to read it now I'm clearly going
to go go get it now so I I think that
one of the most interesting things about
you know watching these kids build
things is that they are so proud of
their efforts and and so invested and
when we talk about young people today
and and many of the you know the the
challenges facing them so often they
feel out of control they feel depressed
they feel that you know they feel not
optimistic about the world around them
and in so many ways entrepreneurship and
really just the the entrepreneurial
mindset you don't have to be starting a
company but but having that mindset that
I have control of my life I'm going to
do things that are going to make the
world a better place I'm going to gather
with a few friends and make the changes
that I can make that can really I I
didn't see the same uh issues that that
I see in in young people in America in
general so much at Babson because they
were empowered they they really felt
that they could make a change they could
they could do something with their lives
and and that they weren't just subject
to all of these really huge Trends
whether it's you know climate change or
whether it's just the country Ai and
automation political climate AI all of
these things that just feel overwhelming
to people right now
um the idea that you can be engaged in
something that is going to try to at
least control your world and maybe have
an impact on the broader world is a is a
very comforting and and empowering
feeling for young people you know what I
find to be the antidote for anxiety and
depression uh is action and agency uh
it's this locus of control is what we
used to call it at Venture for America
but it's look like you control
your own certainly your own State of
Mind well you know you can't totally
control that but you can influence that
your behavior you can take action one of
the reasons why I enjoy what we're doing
with forward so much is I only feel
better about a problem if I'm doing
something about it and if you don't do
anything about it then the problem can
really really plague you that's right
and and I think that entrepreneurship
also teaches you to take reasonable
risks right people often think of
entrepreneurs as big Risk Takers and but
they aren't they they try to measure
like what's a risk I can afford to take
and and invest in that but by that
incremental risk taking you really
become more Brave and more wise about
what what the risk really entails and
that's a lot of the concerns that people
have today are around this notion that
they they can't take risks because the
the outside forces are so strong and
when starting starting a new party right
it's a big risk and a lot of people say
to me oh what you know like what are you
thinking it's not it's going to take 20
years you have to start somewhere and
you have to take a risk it's not that
big of a risk it's a bigger doing
nothing I hope forward becomes the party
of entrepreneurs and Entrepreneurship
and building and agency and giving us
back control of our own Futures but I I
couldn't agree more with the the
sentiment you just expressed that most
of the risks people are talking about
are Phantom risks
I think that drives me nuts that there
are so many people that's like oh can't
do this can't do that it's like wait a
minute there's a bigger risk of us
sitting around and waiting for uh the
bad things to overtake us uh you're you
know that's that's or when I was young
and I started my first company that
totally flopped by the way
um I thought that the risk was looking
in the mirror 30 years later and not
having done anything
um which by the way you know I was like
well that's a risk I could control like
I could uh you know I can at least take
a few shots at something
um and when I was recruiting for Venture
for America I told my wife this story
the other day and she thought it was
really funny what I said to a bunch of
22 year olds I said look things might
not always work out for you if you head
down this entrepreneurial path but at
least you'll be able to remember what
year it was like at least you'll be able
to remember what the heck you were doing
and that gave Evelyn a real laugh but
it's to me really I think people tend to
very much overweight certain risks to
your point and then underweight others
when I was working at the center for
advancing the American dream I got to
meet a lot of entrepreneurs who had come
here from other countries and had had
specifically chosen to start their their
firms and their Ventures here in the U.S
even though they were from Europe or
Russia or Africa or South South America
where you know all over the world but
they they felt that the environment here
was more conducive to success and and
starting new Ventures and part of that
was that we believe in forgiveness and
new starts you know New Beginnings for
people so failure isn't this permanent
State of Affairs like you know that's
the guy who started a business once oh
well you know it failed and he's a
failure forever it's more like you can
be proud of the fact that you tried to
do something whether it failed or
succeeded you can be proud of it I'm
proud of running for office for however
many times I did and I failed way more
times than I succeeded so I you know I
think that we in America have you know
we take it for granted that we have this
notion of allowing people to begin again
and and have infinite numbers of of
lives and and careers and expressions
oh yeah I think I'm on my fourth career
Carrie
if I had to can you catalog it you're
young um but I I think there is
something very important about the
Immigrant experience uh I'm the child of
immigrants myself
and my parents worked very hard uh and
we we felt appreciative of the
opportunities here uh in the U.S uh and
when people come from other parts of the
world I think they have a real
appreciation for what the U.S provides
um meanwhile a lot of young people are
feel like hey the American dream is not
real for me or it's dead uh so you spent
several years trying to combat that at
the brand new center for the advance of
the American dream what did you find
um so actually I'll give a little bit of
backdrop stuff so when I ran for
president I would talk to people about
the American dream and as a numbers guy
said look here to me is what the
American dream is we expect our kids to
do better than we did or if you're a
young person you expect to be better off
than your parents were now do young
people right now expect that most of
them do not and the numbers are that
they're probably right not to because as
things are less affordable and less
accessible if you were born in the 60s
there was something like a 93 chance
you're going to do better than your
parents by the time the 90s rolled
around it's down to a 50 50 shot because
you can actually measure outcomes for
that stuff and it's declining so there
is some empirical reality behind young
people saying you know what the American
dream might not be there for me right
now we have something of a National
Housing affordability crisis in part
because of our dysfunctional politics I
would suggest so describe your work at
the center or what you found uh what
were the the victories and challenges
yeah well first of all I wasn't trying
to convince anyone to believe in it I
really wanted to understand whether it
existed you know because the people who
have experienced it believe in it deeply
and it's it's unshakable because that's
their Lo that's their lived experience
right they they worked hard they
followed the rules they came maybe from
another country where there was
oppression or some you know financial
crisis and they came to America and they
made incredible sacrifices in some cases
and and succeeded and so I think that
while other people might say my
experience has been very different I
followed all the rules things went
poorly for me or maybe the rules weren't
Made For Me Maybe the rules were
actually made to exclude me and make
sure that it was harder for me to
succeed and I'm I'm just you know
exhausted with trying and I don't think
I'm going to do better than my parents
and and I don't see the pathway forward
so so there were these two paths that
that you know that you saw there very
clearly and there wasn't a lot of
understanding and and a lot of
commonality to the experience that these
two groups of people in America have and
what's interesting is they they're not
the the typical they might not even be
the very rich and the very poor
um it there's a whole Center ground of
people who believe very strongly in the
American dream and they feel like
they're on that path but when we did
focus groups we would find for example
that there are certain things that can
knock people off the path to the
American dream that really scare people
and some of those things are Health
crises and I I think Access to Health
Care in America is arguably one of the
the major things that is that are making
people doubt the um the ability and the
the certainty of a path to the American
dream for themselves and their families
and so you mentioned housing as well you
know housing costs and and how that goes
so I think there are certain things that
we can address through policy in in
America right now that will will make
people feel more comfortable that the
promise of America is actually available
to them and in Massachusetts when we did
Health Care reform we've now gotten it
to the point where somewhere between 98
and 99 of the people in Massachusetts
have access to health care it's not as
affordable as as it ought to be but
there is access to health care and the
state as a whole if you look at the
statistics over the last 15 years that
access to basic health care has made us
a healthier state in Massachusetts there
are you know far fewer cardiac problems
or far fewer you know people dying of
cancer Etc so so I think these I think
that these are really important things
for us to think about like what are
those big obstacles to the American
dream that we can start chipping away on
to give people more hope I love it and I
think that is what it would take because
so the American dream has been very real
for me and my family so so incredibly
grateful but as a numbers person I look
up and say you know what let's try and
address the the basics here by the way
your your work in Massachusetts with uh
mitt ended up becoming something of a
national model I
believe I mean it was more or less the
template for Obamacare
yes and and you know I wish that uh we
had been able to work across the aisle
uh with the Obama Administration to talk
about how best to to formulate yeah
there were some pretty big problems with
that design yeah it's a very tough thing
to parse out
um and there are a lot of things that we
still need to do they're they're you
know sort of three aspects to providing
Health Care obviously there's quality
and there's access and there's cost and
so we had great quality of Health Care
in Massachusetts already uh we addressed
the access but we left office before we
could really dig into how do you contain
costs how do you create the kind of
transparency and pricing and and the and
how do you Empower individuals to choose
the the most efficient and and least uh
expensive option for themselves so we we
still have work to do there all right
check it out Carrie I'm going to run
this by you so uh so you've interacted
more with Healthcare than just about
anyone the costs do creep cup uh just
keep on creeping up I want to say last I
checked it was something like 17 of the
economy and Rising uh and here's my
general thesis let's see what you think
hundreds of millions of Americans
one penalized for their kids than
themselves and you and I are parents so
we want the same thing we keep making
the fundamentals of a middle class life
tougher and tougher to come by
um where you have health care it just
gets more and more onerously expensive
because you have these uh companies and
institutions that their business model
essentially is like well I'm going to
increase my pricing by five percent this
year because that's how I get make more
money and I'm a publicly traded company
um so one of my jokes when I was running
for president was you know what no
American has ever gotten a letter from
their insurance company saying uh hey
great news we're cheaper this year
no one's ever gotten that letter
um so you have a health care
infrastructure that gets more and more
costly uh and then you have an
educational path that gets more and more
costly where the the cost of a college
degree how much was it when you and I
went to school uh ish I mean you know
well when when I when I went to college
um all in with uh room housing and and
food and and college my whole tuition
bill was fifteen thousand dollars yeah I
mean people hear that they're shocked
because today it might be four times
that well yes but but my mother was the
sole support of our my family and she
was a school teacher an elementary
schools teacher in the public schools
and she was making twelve thousand
dollars a year then yeah so you know so
so it was still an overwhelming cost and
I had to rely on grants and working and
we you know we sacrificed a lot and sold
everything we could solve sell to to get
me through college but for my in my case
it was the gateway to opportunity and so
it was worthwhile and my mom invested in
it with this Blind Faith that immigrants
have around the value of Education in
America she was a first generation
American my grandmother came from
Germany that she and her parents were
were fleeing a political oppression
there and she arrived in Ellis Island
with like four dollars with her mom I
recently found their record
um when I visited Ellis Island and it
was just so moving to realize you know
how old she was she was like nine years
old and they had you know no money and
it was just it's an incredible thing and
then to imagine that she was my
grandmother and and I've been able to do
what I've been able to do here in
America
the American dream isn't always
immediate it's it's generational and and
so we have to think about you know what
are we what opportunities are we
providing for those next Generations
what will my grandchildren be
experiencing
think about the term private citizen
keyword private that's what you want to
be when you go online but unfortunately
not a whole lot we do is kept to
ourselves nowadays it's more like
exposed Who Wants To Be An exposed
citizen not you not me to keep my data
private when I go online I turn to
expressvpn because it's incredibly easy
to use to secure my data and it can do
the same for you it will reroute your
connection and mask your IP address so
basically everyone cannot see what
you're doing and you too can do what you
like in the privacy of your own internet
so if like me you believe that your data
is your business secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN on the market
go to expressvpn.com Yang don't forget
to use my link so you can get three
extra months free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang expressvpn.com to learn
more
foreign
I was just on Ellis Island last month so
it was a profound experience it's very
powerful isn't it my my family didn't
come through there but it was still very
very profound uh lovely lovely
environment so we have uh healthcare
costs going up uh higher education costs
going up housing costs going up and so a
lot of Americans are looking up saying
hey wait a minute my kids can't afford a
home they can't afford this education if
they get sick they're you know gonna go
bankrupt where we're trying to avoid our
Health Care system at all costs and so
Americans are getting more and more
saddened and frustrated that the that
these things are more and more
oppressive seeming or out of their reach
and in my mind it is because of a
dysfunctional political system that
looks at this in shrugs and it's like
well you know like what's that
Healthcare uh premiums are crazy
expensive I guess that's just the new
state of nature it's a new natural law
and then colleges now whatever it is 65
000 a year for some institutions even
public institutions I want to say are
you know in the tens of thousands for
sure Anew also a new natural law you
know we can't build affordable housing
like I guess that's just the way the
ball bounces
um and so Americans look up and and like
they feel like they're subject to forces
beyond their control
um in part because our political system
doesn't actually respond I I think that
it's our responsibility to lay out
Alternatives so in terms of the cost of
higher education for example we need to
speak about and respect uh Alternatives
that do not include higher education as
we currently imagine it not everyone
needs a college degree to lead a
fulfilling life or even a life that more
than pays the bills and so the idea that
we should be encouraging and expanding
the number of people who are able to go
into the trades trade unionists do very
well and they're very needed and so why
are we not as as people who have been
involved with government why isn't
government making it easier for more
people to go through high school and
college and or just high school and and
graduate with access to the trades that
seems like a very obvious thing there
are a lot of technical skills that can
be given now through short courses
whether they're six months long or less
and and there are a number of Great
Courses that are being created by meta
and Google and IBM and others that can
help you enter those careers that maybe
cost only a couple hundred dollars or
less in order to get that training they
could be done at community colleges they
could be done contemporaneously in your
senior year in high school so that again
you know we could make it so that
everyone would graduate with at least
some skill that would allow them to go
directly into the workforce and not take
on the the tens of thousands of dollars
of debt that are dragging down young
people and making it hard for them to
buy houses making it hard for them to
have kids and to marry and all the
things that they arguably want to do so
so I think that we need to talk about
those alternatives to flesh out those
alternatives for people and also by the
way online education can be incredibly
less expensive and also high quality I'm
on the board of something called Western
Governors University and each year at
Western Governors which is a
competency-based university only costs
seven thousand dollars and you can go as
fast as you want and take as many
courses as you want during each semester
and and most people graduate in well
fewer than four years so you can get an
entire college education which is a very
high quality for less than thirty
thousand dollars and so I think that
people need to start thinking about what
are those real alternatives to the way
that we've learned to live our lives we
don't have to continue doing the same
thing you know what AI is not going to
automate HVAC repair window retrofitters
there's so many things that we're going
to actually need people to do uh and
we're not making it easy enough for
folks to go down those roads we're
stigmatizing it it's bad for young men
who aren't going to go to college in
particular I don't know what the gender
ratio was at Babson but now uh three out
of every five college students is a
woman which on one level is great but
then you know like you have a lot of men
who are falling behind in various ways
Carrie we we should put you in charge of
something very big and important I think
that a lot of people listening to this
would
maybe building helping you build the
forward party yeah no it seems Seems big
and important so so
what are your uh hopes for forward now
that you're helping us steer this thing
for me I'm looking at it as a 20-year
project something I want to be involved
with for the rest of my life uh it's
something that we need to really build a
solid foundation for uh in order to
transform American democracy in a way
that it can be responsive to everyone
and and so that everyone can have a home
so that no one would be feeling as I
have throughout my entire career that I
didn't really fit here I didn't really
fit there and therefore I was constantly
having to operate on the fringes of of
our political party system I would like
to see a party where everyone is welcome
where it's constructive where it isn't a
a place where we we're trying to
leverage Conflict for our own Advantage
which is obviously what goes on now with
our our two-party system our duopoly if
you will so those are the things that
I'd like to see and and I'd love to be
able to have serious talks about things
like immigration uh that you know we
need to solve this problem we can't just
continue to use it as a way to win
elections we need to talk about public
service I you know I would genuinely
love to see national service me too be
something that a majority of young
people in America view is just part of
growing up I want the first question
that people ask each other later in
their 20s is like oh where did you do
your national service and and what did
you do and what did you learn from that
so we need to find ways to knit the
country back together again culturally
and I think that this party is a way of
doing that leverage Solutions not
conflict build over the long term though
I think we're going to surprise a lot of
people and what we can get done uh in
much much uh faster Pace than the next
20 years Carrie Healy welcome aboard
thank you so much for helping us lead
this effort and The Best Is Yet To Come
I really do want to put you in charge of
something awesome when I say you know
like I mean feel like you could overhaul
America's Health Care System education
system just about any system we have and
make it better thank you Andrew and
thank you for getting the ball rolling
on on the forward party and I'm really
excited about what we can do in the
coming year and Beyond yeah me too
thank you